things are very rapidly escalating in
Russia we've been waiting and wondering
well what is Putin's eventual move here
what was expected by some to be an
extremely rapid total defeat of Ukraine
of course did not happen
uh and over the last couple of weeks we
have seen Russian forces actually
repelled and retreating and the question
amid continued concerns about Vladimir
Putin's Health has been what is the end
game how is he going to ultimately get
out of this or is he ultimately going to
get out of this the U.S embassy is now
warning Americans to get out of of
Russia this is uh the clearest
declaration and the most comprehensive
of you just have to get out now many of
you might be saying why are there
Americans still in Russia uh there are
so many different reasons why there are
Americans still in Russia and we're
going to talk about that in a moment a
CNN reporting
the U.S embassy in Moscow issued a
security alert overnight that again
urged U.S citizens to leave Russia
immediately while there are still
options for departing the country the
alert comes in the wake of Russian
President Putin's order for partial
mobilization of Russian men to fight in
his war in Ukraine
quote Russia May refuse to acknowledge
dual Nationals U.S citizenship deny
their access to U.S Consular assistance
prevent their departure from Russia and
conscript dual Nationals for military
service that is a really scary statement
which we will talk about
the embassy has consistently warned
Americans not to travel to Russia and to
depart the country immediately if there
the embassy alert urged U.S citizens to
quote avoid all political or social
protests do not photograph security
Personnel at these events noting that
the right to Peaceful assembly and
freedom of expression are not guaranteed
in Russia
very different situation that Americans
in Russia have to understand
leaving is a very good idea at this
point but at the same time there are
people who simply didn't research the
situation properly who are there now one
of the things that's important to
understand about the dual citizenship
thing if you are in a country in which
you hold citizenship and you hold an
additional citizenship meaning you are
an American citizen and you are a
Russian Citizen and you are in Russia
it is often the case that in that
country you are only viewed through the
lens of that citizenship if you were
a French American dual Citizen and you
were in Russia this is not an issue if
you are an American Russian dual Citizen
and you were in Russia the American
citizenship isn't particularly relevant
at least not as far as Russia cares if
you are a russian-american dual Citizen
and you're in Russia and Russia says hey
you know what we're we're conscripting
individuals to fight in the military and
you go oh no uh I need help from the
American Embassy because I'm also an
American citizen it is very common that
that will be denied to you now the uh
American authorities might say well we
can still try to help but you will often
be denied Consular Services because at
the end of the day you are a Russian
Citizen and this is something that
um uh yeah I've I've talked about and
thought about in other terms with regard
to my Argentinian dual citizenship where
um there have been discussions of what
if x y or Z happen while in Argentina
this is obviously much more serious and
and much more significant now some
reactions I've read are more or less
like shouldn't these Americans have
already left
um I I'm actually I'm sympathetic to the
people that are there and that are also
American citizens it is really difficult
to uproot your life there are lots of
people
whose entire lives despite being
American Russian dual citizens their
entire lives are in Russia they were
born in the U.S to Russian parents and
went to Russia at age three okay that's
that's an American citizen nominally
whose entire life is arguably in Russia
and so the idea of well just get out
what are you doing there uh it's a more
complicated statement than than might
appear the other thing about this is
that not everybody has the money or
financial resources to get out and to
come back to the United States it may
not be obvious how they would make a
living in the United States if you are
working in Russia and this is often
something that comes up when we talk
about undocumented immigration to the
United States and many on the right love
to pretend that people that come to the
United States illegally kind of doing it
on a whim kind of doing it for fun for
entertainment almost like some kind of
Tourism of some sense and what's often
missing from that conversation is that
these are people's lives and uprooting
or moving your life to a different
country is a really really big deal and
so even when you are coming to the
United States undocumented from uh
Central South America looking for work
as as is this typical situation that we
talk about that's a massive decision
that no one makes lightly and it's often
missing total lack of empathy when we
talk about and think about what it is
that these folks are doing here not
related to hey Americans it's time to
get out of Russia but that also is going
on but these folks are not on vacation
is the important thing to understand
um and this now gets us back to
what is Putin willing to do how far is
Putin willing to go what is he
potentially considering and is Putin
sick is Putin erratic is Putin not
thinking clearly and the answers to all
of these questions uh May well be yes so
no there are some very non-trivial
decisions to be made by Americans in
Russia
and the next four to six weeks of what
Putin does or doesn't do could be
extremely important in terms of the
entire course that this war is going to
take scary moment and yes uh all other
caveats aside people have lives people
are all these things that we've talked
about for people living in Russia the
recommendation is to get out my
preference would be not to end up
potentially conscripted into the Russian
army now of course I am not a Russian
dual Citizen and I have no connections
to Russia so it's easy for me to say
I've seen several people in my life try
to quit smoking or vaping and quitting
has so many benefits but it does require
a strategy and our sponsor fume is a
one-of-a-kind inhaler that can help you
quit smoking as a replacement for the
hand-to-mouth habit of smoking there is
no smoke there is no vapor and there's
no nicotine fume is just a small inhaler
handcrafted from wood it uses cores
infused with fresh aromatic plant oils
for you to taste and enjoy instead of a
nasty cigarette or a vape you can use
fume while flying which is a big plus
because there's no smoke no Vapor no
nicotine fume has flavors like
peppermint and Conquer with a powerful
minty sensation to simulate the menthol
cigarettes they have other flavors like
cozy chai I love chai myself and lemon
berry Bliss for a sweeter experience
fume has helped thousands of people quit
people who have tried everything else
read the reviews we talked to the fume
team they're very proud of the lives
that they've impacted throw out the
cigarettes get rid of the Vapes head
over to
breathefume.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman to get 10 off your entire order
the link is down below